is a village of just 260 people but its
residents have made 17 call outs in the
last fortnight to this bomb disposal
team
this home was hit three days ago and
they're checking for any unexploded
munitions in the debris
the family of four were in a neighboring
village when their house got hit
remnants of their life are now mixed
with rubble
is
most villagers have already left and now
they have no choice
in the mikaliv region there are 2 000
outstanding civilian applications
this was a sawyer powder factory
it's not just communities picking up the
pieces the war has left a gaping hole in
the country's industry
russia may have struggled against
ukraine's military but it has damaged it
economically the world bank saying that
the economy here has shrunk by 45 per
cent and if putin wants to continue to
[ __ ] it he will focus his attentions
here in the south
these stationary grain wagons on the
edge of mikalive a reminder that one of
the world's biggest exporters of wheat
has almost ground to a halt
ninety-eight percent of ukraine's
cereals are exported through the
southern ports but russia has blockaded
the black sea
and it's been blowing up fuel supplies
this one on the edge of mikael ive not
far from the front line has been hit by
what looks like an air strike
this drum behind me is partially damaged
but the one next to it has been
completely obliterated and parts of it
have blasted a hundred meters away near
to the roadside then you can see the
crater where the bombs landed and
further beyond that another fuel drum
that has been battered beyond
recognition
and for all the sanctions on russia it's
ukraine where industry is battered
workers have fled exports has stemmed
and who would holiday on these beaches
this summer
its economic ruin which would be
complete if russian forces are able to
press across mikolai of southern bug
river take the trading post of odessa
and landlock ukraine
jason farrell sky news nick alive